ت تعال ت
تاللا بس رنا زي اخواتنا الكبار لانهم وقت
ما بدنا اياهم بلاقيهم يعني انا مثلا لما
يكون مثلا ما حدش من اهلي عندي بزعق باسم
يساعدني مثلا في الحركه في الوضوء في
المشي انه امشي لازم اكون معي مرافق وقت
المشي فباسم دائما بقول لي يلا امشيك يلا
تحرك ليش قاعد ف وبرضو خالت ران دايما
بتسال ابعت لك خبز ابعت لك كذا فيعني
دائما بنلاقيه موجودين يعني حتى بدون ما
نسال
عن جنا بالفلفل الدون الشطه انا والله كنت
موجوده هنا في المستشفى من اول الحرب يعني
تقريبا قنا الحين شهرين وشويه تقريبا 70
يوم زي كده او اكثر وجينا في الاول مع
قرايبنا كانوا مصابين جايين نزحوا من غزه
على خان يونس وقصف في خان يونس فهم كان ما
كانش لهم حدا يقعد معاهم فجينا هنا وكان
انا وباسم جينا مع بعض فلما خلصوا
الاصابات او تعافوا قريبنا المصابين جينا
عمالنا بنربط اغراضنا وبنا نروح لو انه
جايبين جايبين البنت هذه على المستشفى
كاننا في الاستقبال وبعدين جابين هنا على
القسم
[موسيقى]
هذا يعني احنا مش بنساعد بس كنا قريبنا بس
لا بنساعد كل القسم في كل حاجه كل شيء حتى
في شرقه الاغراض حتى في لو مثلا واحده ب
بدها تشيل ب تعمل مريض بدها تحركه بتنادي
باسم لو واحده بدها تشتري اغراض تشتري خض
تشتري اي اكل اي حاجه انا اروح انزل على
السوق كثير ناس بيجوا طلبوا بتقوللي بدي
نف خبزه لابني بعطيها حتى لو معيش انا
بروح بلف على اي واحده معاها وبقولها
اديني بس الرغيف
للولد انا هنا كان دوري اول ما جيت من اول
الحرب كانت اختي مصابه طلعناها من تحتدم
ماتوا 12 نفر من العائله وانا كنت
مضد تبعها في كل حاجه ايش كانت بها كنت
انا اسويه اخذت سحبات اوليه خاصه كنت مع
اختي في المستشفى ولما ان طلعت استلمنا
البنت هذ اول ما طلعنا واستعنا فيها
مالهاش ولا ابو ولا ام ولا
حدا كنت الف مع زمايلي على
الجرحه بدهم مساعده كنت اساعدهم من حروق
لكسر لبتر لنزيف داخلي كنت اساعدهم بس ما
كنتش البس المريول كان نفسي البسه اتهم
كلهم زي اخواني كلهم بنات صغار حتى كانت
لو ست كبيره بعتبرها زي امي او ستي ايش ما
بدها بساعدها بعديها فتحت المجال اشحن
بطاريات اشحن جوالات اللي بده يعجن اللي
بده يعمل شاي اعمل له شاي ايش كان بدهم
كون تعملهم في الغرفه كان هم يعملوا
العجين وانا اخبزه
للناس